one of the women running in the women's
section of the London Marathon
is someone named Glenn who for the last
two years has gone by glenick
Glenn Frank
who just gave an interview to the Press
on what
his performance in the London Marathon
means for girl power not your first math
and I believe no this will be 17 and I'm
doing the six Majors so I've just done
takedown
Chicago Berlin 2024 will be the number
six and then that's the week before
London so a week rest but girl power
girl power
it's you have to laugh a little bit
because you the other choice would be to
cry
if this news reporter had interviewed
any actual woman do you think the woman
would have ended her interview by saying
girl power
yeah yeah you know well listen here John
and George always love to talk about
Bill power that's the only British
accent I can really do is Paul McCartney
No they wouldn't have
they wouldn't feel the need to call
attention
to the fact that they are women because
they know that they're women and
everyone knows that they're women okay
we can move on
the transgender movement
insists upon this this is why they wear
the most ridiculous clothing this is why
they're constantly talking about
Womanhood this is why they're constantly
harping on their pronouns and how
wonderful it is to be a woman this is
why Dylan Mulvaney has made his entire
now quite lucrative career on what what
it is to be a woman every single day
this isn't just about some people with
some quirky sexual ideas trying to pass
and live their own lives in society it's
never been about that
it's always about forcing this
Preposterous ideology down everybody's
throat
every single public expression of
transgenderism amounts to this guy's
interview
yeah girl power yeah I'm a woman 365th
day of being a woman I'm a woman I'm she
oh gosh being a woman it's so hard we
got to go out shopping buy dresses oh I
just love being a woman I'm a woman look
at me look at me and
they do this
because they want you to lie
they want it to be impossible for you to
ignore or politely sort of Turn Your
Eyes away from their
absurdity
you have to engage with it
and you have to go along with it and you
have to assent to it you have to affirm
it you have to lie
you have to lie
if we
establish transgenderism in public life
you will have to lie that is the point
there's no getting away there's no Live
and Let Live it was never about Live and
Let Live right now go to ramp.com
Knowles do you want a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses vendor payments and accounting
if so ramp could be a complete game
changer for your business ramp is a
corporate card and expense management
software designed to help you save time
and money with ramp you can issue cards
to every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense
reporting so you can stop wasting time
at the end of every month ramps
accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to the time you'll save each month on
employee expenses will allow you to
close your books eight times faster
businesses that use Ram save an average
of three and a half percent within the
first year ramp is easy to use get
started in less than 15 minutes whether
you have five employees or five thousand
right now you can get 250 off when you
join ramp go to ramp.com
Knowles kwles that is r a m p.com slash
Knowles cards issued by Sutton Bank and
Celtic Bank members FDIC terms and
conditions apply a widow named Jessica
Bates wants to adopt children out of the
foster care system
she lives in the state of Oregon
she can't do it
she can't do it why
because
she's Christian
Jessica Bates was widowed some six years
ago in a car accident
she was already months into the adoption
process when she noticed an emphasis on
supporting
lgbtism the LGBT movement
specifically respecting accepting and
supporting the sexual orientation or
gender identity of any child placed into
her home
so she could get a little boy to take in
and care for out of the foster care
system and then one day the boy says I'm
actually a little girl and the Foster
the adoption system says you have to
treat the little boy as a little girl
she says well I can't do that that would
be a lie it's just not true and it's
certainly out of line with my Christian
beliefs
and so
foster care system says okay well you
can't have a kid
you can't adopt a kid
the thruple the gay throuple three dudes
that we talked about on the show last
week
they can adopt a child no problem
but this lovely Christian Widow is not
allowed to adopt a child out of the
foster care system not even a newborn
child newborn children are harder to
adopt she can't even take in a poor kid
out of the foster care system because
she's Christian according to the system
it would be child abuse if she took in
that kid the gay throuple takes in a kid
that's wonderful that's so beautiful
that should get headlines all over the
world but a Christian woman takes in a
kid no that's child abuse
and it has to be one or the other
it ha the answer to this problem is not
tolerance the answer to this problem is
not diversity the answer to this problem
is not wow can you believe how crazy the
foster care system is yeah it is crazy
but think about it from their
perspective
the foster care system believes the
foster care system in this case just
being an arm of the state representing
the crazy ideas that have recently been
enshrined in our law they they view the
situation as
some men are born in the bodies of women
some women are born in the bodies of men
there is no higher moral calling than to
do whatever feels good sensually and
physically
and so if you are a
you think you're a woman but you're in
the physical form of a man
you need to have access to cross-ex
hormones you need to have the ability to
chop off your genitals you need to wear
stilettos in a dress you need to be
called she and her you need to otherwise
you'll contradict your true self you'll
become anxious you'll become depressed
you'll become suicidal it would it would
be child abuse for a trans kid to be
raised in a Christian home that's what
they believe that's the idea enshrined
in our law certainly in Oregon but in a
lot of places around the country frankly
even at the federal level because of
those two stupid Supreme Court decisions
in 2020 Bostock and the Harris Funeral
Homes case which enshrines the idea of
transgenderism in the federal law until
we can undo it once we get enough
conservative judges and enough political
momentum
that's probably not going to happen
anytime soon might have to wait a little
while as we had to wait with Roe v Wade
but we can build toward that
and we have to do that because the
consequence of enshrining that into law
is that Christian women are not allowed
to adopt kids but gayth Rebels are
it has to be that way
or conversely if boys can't really be
girls and if sexually confused little
boys and girls should not be pumped full
of poison and have their genitals
chopped off
and if the science shows the largest
data set on this shows that actually the
transgender procedures Surgical and
hormonal do not alleviate depression and
anxiety and suicidality and all the
other conditions associated with
transgender ideology if actually at
least in one case in the case of anxiety
they make the condition worse
well then that would be child abuse in
in in that world if all of that stuff is
true which it obviously is then to raise
a child and raise a little boy and
pretend he's a little girl that's child
abuse and that person should not be
allowed to adopt children and the gay
throuple with all the crazy sexual ideas
and anthropological ideas that Trio
should not be allowed to adopt kids but
it has to be one or the other because
the state has a legitimate interest in
preventing child abuse and so therefore
the state has to form ideas on what
child abuse is so what's child abuse
raising a kid to believe in God and
believe in all the stuff that all the
wise people from our generation from I'm
sorry from our civilization have always
believed across the generations
or to tell a kid that he's really the
opposite sex
and pump them full of poison and chop
them up which is child abuse we all know
the answer to that
but our present-day culture will not
tolerate the true answer
we use a small handful of liberal Elites
are working in concert with the
principalities and the powers of this
world to suppress the truth and to
promote evil it's exactly what Tucker
alluded to in his Heritage Foundation
speech
and that's the sort of thing you're not
allowed to say you're at least not
allowed to say it on mainstream cable TV
on the biggest name in news you're not
allowed to say that it's too true
we gotta pick one
what are we going to live according to
as Tucker made beautifully clear in his
speech we used to think of Politics as
you write your white paper and I write
my white paper and we have a
debate of ideas over which policy is
going to be conducive toward the end
that we all agree on
that's over
that's over now the question is
do kids get to be raised in a Christian
household period or are they going to be
raised by the throuple transiting them
you pick
it's your it's your Society it's
supposed to be your Society it's
supposed to be a self-government is it
still I'm not sure it was a really great
clip I know I agree if you want more of
them you got to subscribe ring that Bell
hit that like
Punk that horn I don't know whatever you
have to do subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time
[Music]